it is with a heavy heart that we report
that actor Cameron Boyce has sadly
passed away on July 6 2019 the beloved
Disney Channel star touched so many
lives and will forever be remembered as
a ray of sunshine that warmed the hearts
of anyone and everyone today and every
day moving forward we pay tribute to the
lovely soul that is Cameron Boyce
[Music]
Kameron managed to inspire so many
people throughout his short 20 years of
life and natural on the stage Cameron
grew up embracing the arts and
everything that came with it no matter
how famous he became his big heart and
welcoming personality always managed to
shine through inspiring others to follow
in his footsteps a spokesperson for the
boy's family informed CNN that Cameron
had tragically passed away in his sleep
after suffering a seizure the incident
occurred as a result of an ongoing
medical condition that Cameron was being
treated for the actor's sudden passing
took us all by surprise and we can all
agree that the world will never feel the
same without his brightest ray of light
Cameron had just celebrated his 20th
birthday on May 28th he was young kind
absolutely adorable and everything a
person could want in a friend and role
model chairman's loved her performing
led him to pursue an acting career when
he was only nine years old his talent
illuminated stages proving that he was
born to shine Cameron was currently
working in a number of projects he was
set to play Simon in Paradise City he
was also set to star as Kyle in the
upcoming movie runt which is still in
post-production
however Cameron was already filming for
the TV series mrs. Fletcher the late
great actor had his entire career ahead
of him and he was undoubtedly going to
change the world with his giving and
caring personality however there's no
doubt in our minds that Cameron after
a better place than he found it back in
2008 a young and adorable Cameron boys
played the role of Michael Kate's jr. on
General Hospital nightshift in 2010
Cameron was cast in grownups where he
acted alongside big-time actors like
Adam Sandler Salma Hayek David Spade and
many more
once Cameron got the ball rolling his
career took off in a flash he was a
triple threat in every sense of the word
the boy could sing and dance his way
into your heart in a matter of seconds
Cameron soon joined the elite squad of
Disney Channel stars which opened up
many doors for him before he knew it he
was landing a huge and permanent role on
the adored TV series Jesse
Cameron portrayed Luke Ross for a total
of four years and during this time his
fan base
only continued to grow and grow in 2015
Cameron was chosen to play Carlos
Seville on descendants this was the role
of a lifetime and would eventually lead
to Cameron starring in an unforgettable
trilogy it's hard to imagine anyone else
trying to fill Carlos de Vil's platform
boots but no one could ever measure up
to the legends that is Cameron voiced
the star nailed every dance move
making classic spins look like a total
breeze much like himself
Cameron's character Carlos was known for
being a kind hearted individual who had
an affinity for chocolate it didn't take
long for fans to fall in love with
Cameron on and off the screen his bright
smile unique dusting of freckles and
warm eyes maybe want to know more about
the actor many of chairman's fans have
confessed that their childhood wouldn't
be the same without Cameron's presence
he touched so many lives and had plans
to touch so many more descendants fans
have been impatiently waiting for
descendants three to
on August 2nd 2019 but now watching
Cameron dance across the screen is going
to be bittersweet being a part of the
Disney Channel family gave Cameron and
abundance of opportunities and he never
took a single one for granted no matter
which TV show or movie Cameron was
filming he always can ported himself
with grace and humility he opened his
heart to everyone and was a joy to work
with and a pleasure to know despite
being a huge star
Cameron never let fame get to his head
and he always made sure to give back to
the community
Cameron never took his life for granted
and was involved in many philanthropic
causes his most prominent one being the
thirst project which was a nonprofit
organization that helps provide
communities with safe drinking water the
news of Cameron's passing made its way
around the world early on Sunday July
7th the world is still in a state of
disbelief over Cameron's tragic death
Cameron's family reported that they are
utterly heartbroken they also asked fans
to respect their privacy during this
immensely difficult time
Cameron was born and raised in Los
Angeles where he quickly expressed a
great interest in the Performing Arts
he blew people away during variety shows
receiving standing ovations before he
was even 8 years old the Disney Channel
dubbed Cameron a veteran actor at age 19
and have extended their deepest
condolences to his family
cast Mayes colleagues and friends you
didn't need to know Cameron firsthand to
know that he was an old soul who loved
anyone and everyone leave some kind
words in the comments section to pay
homage to one of the most beautiful
Souls the world has ever had the chance
to meet we love you Cameron may you rest
in peace
[Music]